I think it's important to me to tell the
truth
Raquel Levis dropping big reveals on
part three of the Vanderpump Rules
reunion I don't want to lie anymore and
it's all out there anyway like the worst
is out it all went down Wednesday night
with Raquel finally revealing the actual
timeline of her romance with Tom
Sandoval I mean I even suggest I was
like maybe like what would Ariana think
about like having me as an addition and
he was like no no she would not be into
that
ruffle yeah because like I love Ariana
as a person and then also I'm in love
with Tom Sandoval so
yeah it didn't seem like that
far-fetched of an idea but it was
not something in question God he's gonna
kill me Vanderpump executive producer
Alex Baskin teased some reveals to The
Hollywood Reporter Tuesday saying that
the cast would have to decide who would
return after watching The Reunion with
the rest of the world so with the crew
for season 11 still unconfirmed what's
next well cameras are expected to be
back up in the next few weeks I'm
excited to return I mean we've been
sharing our lives on TV for 10 seasons
nine for me and I think that I'm just
excited to keep doing that it brings me
a lot of joy to connect with people via
doing the show and so I want to be able
to keep doing that with Ariana being
down to return it's likely that her
sandwich shop partner Katie Maloney's
back too Aryan and I are you know we're
doing our sandwich shop so that's kind
of like
the big thing on big focus and honestly
where like that goes as for Sandoval and
Raquel's future with the franchise
that's a big question mark
in contact with Raquel so that's a bit
of of an unknown quantity to me right
now I think she really needs to discuss
with us what's going on in her life but
Samuel's been part of that group
but
what 15 years prior you know four years
prior to the show I don't think you can
just shut the door on somebody I think
we're all guilty of some things maybe
not that but you know I think at some
point there needs to be kind of
discussions and I think we'll be there
for it I mean I'm not going to be the
one to tell someone they can't film and
stuff I've been on that end of the stick
before you know I remember when they
tried to exclude me out of filming and
it kind of worked back then you know as
the number one guy in the group you know
I want to be I want to be the nice
number one guy in the group I'll leave
it up to the girls really to make that
decision uh but it's not going to be me
that's going to be putting my foot down
or anything like that I'll be honest
[Music]